so Bush Recon phantoms is developed
between nine and eleven different
studios around the world starting here
in Singapore and going all the way
follow the Sun to San Francisco be based
in San Francisco occasionally we've
really come to grips with this and how
we have alternating meetings you'll buy
it we cover a lot of disciplines which
means the European operation is pretty
much covered from here right now a lot
of the software today fun of the video
games today is built around the world
with different hands the challenge comes
with having a standard set of practices
and a standard set of communication
tools after sending messages in bottles
to Singapore which turned out not to be
too effective we tried more traditional
tools for example like Skype food
messages and bottles well fine if the
Germans sent messages and bottles the
issue isn't written in German so working
on such a multicultural team ease is a
phenomenal advantage but it's also a
challenge
a challenge from a holistic perspective
because everybody has to be able to
converse with each other but we're
patient with each other and we learn how
to communicate we build a product that's
not just built for our particular region
of the world we're building a product
for North America for Europe but also
many other parts and in order to do that
you need to be able to take input from
these different people in these
different places so during the close
beta there was definitely a lot of work
involved it was very challenging but I
think it was also a really exciting time
for the entire team we told you we even
had difficulties in the closed beta
closed beta is terrifying you're you
turn the service on and you're you don't
know if the server's are gonna go down
you don't know if the scripts gonna fail
you don't know if a character is gonna
have a bug and animate the wrong way
it's your first real feedback from a
very demanding audience and it can come
as a bit of a shock if you're not used
to it but it's also what makes it so
genuine and so true Ubisoft has been
amazing with us they have been extremely
patience and very understanding of the
type of challenge that they had asked us
to to go through the pressure from the
management team was make sure you're
learning the right lessons and don't
learn them over and over and over again
try to learn and then iterate from that
and grow and then as well teaches a
company and themselves how to do that
for the next product
you've stopped spending
something that people should expect to
really happen